bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches les
missions qui vous vaccine avec rappel
hebdomadaires contre la bêtise
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler des déficits publics bonjour
estelle bonjour olivier bonjour à tous
bienvenue dans ces caches il ne cesse
d'augmenter et devrait atteindre cette
année 9 4% du pib français
un record on parle bien sûr du déficit
public alors est ce grave
faut-il s alarmer jusqu'à quel niveau
peut-il encore se creuser on va en
parler à dans cette émission et pour
cela en deuxième partie nous serons avec
jean marc daniel économiste et
professeur à escp europe à ne pas
confondre avec la dette publique qui
correspond à l'ensemble des emprunts
contractés par l'état le déficit public
lui c'est la différence entre ce que le
pays gagnent les recettes et ce qu'il
dépense alors qu'il était estimé à plus
de 85 milliards d'euros en 2019
il devrait atteindre 220 milliards cette
année chez les détails avec le tiroir
cache dans punch basse
c'est un chiffre qui alarme ces
dernières semaines alors qu'il avait été
d'abord évalué à 8,5 pour cent puis 9%
début avril
bruno le maire ministre de l'économie a
annoncé que le déficit public
atteindrait finalement cette année 9 4%
220 milliards d'euros 41 milliards de
plus que ce qui était prévu en loi de
finances initiale
tout cela s'explique forcément par la
tonne de mesures lancées par l'état pour
sauver les entreprises durant la crise
sanitaire
et pendant que le déficit public
augmente revu à la hausse sans arrêt la
croissance n est toujours négative
le pib a encore reculé de 0 1% au
premier trimestre alors que là encore le
chiffre prévu était une augmentation de
0 4%
mais qu'importe du côté de bercy au
maintien l'objectif de 5% de croissance
sur l'année
il faut dire que si aux états unis on a
récemment après une augmentation de
l'inflation énorme et donc une
potentielle remontée prochaine des taux
d'intérêt de la fed pour freiner cette
inflation la bce elle a redit ya
quelques jours qu'elle allait maintenir
ses mesures de soutien coûte que coûte
et continuez donc à faire tourner la
planche à billets pour reprendre une
expression souvent entendue dans ces
caches
la france a donc encore nous banque
centrale derrière elle et alors que le
dé confinement définitif approche qu'il
n'y a plus qu'à espérer que cette fois
ce sera la bonne et que l'économie
redémarre vraiment comme semble le
penser le ministre de l'économie
olivier nouveau record donc pour le
déficit public mais parallèlement à cela
la croissance devrait rebondir de 5 %
selon les prévisions du gouvernement
faut-il donc réellement s'alarmer et oui
parce que d'abord les prévisions du
gouvernement savait ce que ça vaut pas
grand chose il en sait rien si ça va
rebondir ou pas ils vous prévoyait déjà
un rebond au premier trimestre qui n'a
pas eu lieu
il vous prévoir un rebond au deuxième
trimestre qui n'aura pas forcément lieu
d'ailleurs je vous rappelle que là on
est fin juin
donc les choses ne ne s'améliore que
très lentement et de toute façon il faut
quand même se rendre compte que quand
vous avez un déficit de près de 10% en
fait un quand vous avez un déficit de
près de 10% et que vous allez faire
peut-être quatre peut-être 5% de
croissance
on n'en sait rien pour l'instant et bien
en fait vous êtes en récession de 6 quoi
en gros c'est ça que ça veut dire donc
que quand il faut à chaque fois m 2 pour
avoir un deux d'endettement pour avoir
un de pipe c'est pas une équation qui
durent très longtemps donc là
aujourd'hui vous avez les banques
centrales qui ont passé moi l'expression
le cul entre deux chaises et qui
aujourd'hui sont embêtés parce que à
force de créer de la monnaie est bien
évidemment la monnaie se déprécie et
donc vous avez des commencements
d'inflation en tout cas sur les actifs
financiers risée l'énergie le bet fall
le pétrole et d'autres et d'autres
sources d'inflation et puis ce qu'ils
voudraient normalement dire que la
banque centrale devrait monter les taux
d'intérêt pour essayer de bloquer cette
inflation mais malheureusement elle ne
peut pas bloquer les remonter les taux
d'intérêt parce qu'elle sait à ce moment
là que l'économie s'effondre donc elle
est partagée aujourd'hui que ce soit
d'ailleurs aux états unis ou en europe
entre une activité qui reprend mais qui
apprend très très doucement et qu'il
faut pas tuer dans l'oeuf
et puis une inflation qui a l'air de
démarrer ou en tout cas des
anticipations d'inflation qui ont l'air
de démarrer et à ce moment là il
faudrait remonter les taux mais le
problème c'est que avec le stock de
dettes qu'on a fait ces dernières années
et pas simplement depuis le coc vide
mais depuis 2008
et bien c'est compliqué de remonter les
taux parce que si vous remonter les taux
vous non seulement vous casser la
croissance mais en plus vous avez un tas
de dettes qui vous coûte vraiment
beaucoup plus cher merci beaucoup
olivier tout de suite la deuxième partie
de cette émission
et cette semaine pour évoquer le déficit
public nous sommes en liaison avec jean
marc daniel économiste et professeur à
escp europe bonjour monsieur daniel
merci à d'être une nouvelle fois parmi
nous bonjour alors on l'a vu en première
partie en jean marie danielle le déficit
public à gonfler une fois de plus à quoi
est dû ce déficit record je vous propose
est d'écouter bruno le maire à ce propos
ce déficit est lié à trois choses la
première c'est que nous reportons un
certain nombre de dépenses de 2020 sur
parce que nous continuons à aider un
certain nombre de secteurs et
d'entreprises même si progressivement
nous allons supprimer ces aides et en
troisième lieu parce qu'il y à une
partie du plan de relance qui est
décaissé
voilà pour les explications du ministre
de l'économie donné fin mai jean marc
daniel lorsqu'on entend ces explications
on a un petit peu le sentiment qu'il
faut relativiser
est ce que c'est le cas selon vous alors
je crois qu'il faut relativiser dans la
mesure où je serais moins pessimistes
olivier delamarche sur la croissance on
voit bien que la croissance a été cassé
brisé par un choc exogène qui a été le
confinement imposées par la crise
sanitaire
dès qu'on sort du confit demandé qu'on
arrête les mesures de confinement la
croissance rebondit au troisième
trimestre de l'année dernière on a une
croissance trimestrielle de 18 9%
parce que on espérait on penser que la
pandémie était derrière nous et donc je
pense que la croissance qui va avoir
lieu dans cette année dans la partie
terminale de l'année sera beaucoup plus
soutenu que ce qu'on ne pouvait espérer
et les 5 75% par exemple de croissance
prévu par la banque de france sont à mon
avis assez crédibles ils rejoignent
d'ailleurs les prévisions de l'oscd donc
une des raisons pour lesquelles il ya du
déficit c'est parce qu'on soutient
l'activité économique à cause des
mesures de restriction liée au
confinement et à la pandémie
dès qu'on arrête dès qu'on considère que
la pandémie est derrière nous c'était
dès qu'on accepte il dit que la
vaccination au marché et bien tout peut
redémarrer et les dépenses publiques les
z les soutiens peuvent eux être
supprimées en revanche là où je suis
plus inquiet c'est que l'on continue à
espérer dans l'efficacité d'un plan de
relance qui est totalement inappropriée
et totalement perpendiculaires aux
besoins de l'économie française
d'ailleurs lé ocde a fait un commentaire
assez récemment sur les mesures des
plans de relance divers qui ont été
approuvés dans un certain nombre de pays
en disant que quand on regarde et sur le
terrain on s'apercevrait que les
performances économiques et étaient
assez peu lié aux masses dépensés dans
le cadre de plans de relance donc je
pense que l'enjeu c'est la vaccination
est la spécialité de la crise et que sur
le plan des finances publiques il faut
profiter de la reprise liée à plus ou
moins la fin de la pandémie pour
débrancher un certain nombre de dépenses
qui sont manifestement inutiles
oui ma première réaction à ce qu'il
vient de dire jean marc daniel notamment
sur la croissance
je ne suis pas du tout d'accord pour la
bonne et simple raison qu on le voit
d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup moins
d'étrangers
parce que l'on circule moins est
beaucoup moins facilement donc il ya
beaucoup moins d'étrangers hors cee qui
dépensait beaucoup en france pendant les
vacances
aujourd'hui quand on discute un petit
peu avec avec les restaurateurs et on
s'aperçoit que c'est pas ça c'est à dire
que les les restaurants ont une baisse
d'activité une baisse de la deûle à la
facture moyenne par personne qui est qui
est importante donc il faut pas
s'imaginer que sous prétexte qu'on de
relâche un peu les rênes et puis on les
relâche un peu c'est à dire qu'on est
absolument pas sûr que il va pas y avoir
de mauvaises surprises quand on voit un
peu comment ça se passe même dans des
pays qui ont beaucoup vaccinés ou ya
l'air quand même d'y avoir des reprises
de
de l'infection donc c'est pas dit du
tout qui se passe ce qui se passe rien
d'ici la fin de l'année et donc je crois
qu'il faudrait un tout petit peu revoir
les prévisions en baisse alors c'est
toujours facile de faire des prévisions
extraordinaire de toute façon on sait
qu'elles sont en grande majorité révisé
dans les mois qui suivent donc voilà
mais de toute façon sur les sur les
aides
on voit bien ce que ce que cherche à
faire les le gouvernement français c'est
c'est surtout essayer de les retirer le
plus tard possible parce qu'ils savent
très bien que le jour où on retire les
aides et bien vous allez avoir tout un
lot de chômeurs partiels qui vont
devenir chômeur tout court et donc que
qu'il ya beaucoup d'activités qui sont
tenus à bout de bras et qui le jour où
il n'y a plus de n'y a plus d' aides
vont s'effondrer donc je pense qu'ils
vont essayer de maintenir en tout cas
laissé passer toutes les élections
régionales et autres et puis peut-être
essayer de viser la présidentielle pour
descendre lentement quitte à faire un
déficit de toute façon c'est pas eux
qu'ils géreront donc au final c'est tout
c'est toujours pratique de le faire
quand c'est les autres qui payent alors
justement messieurs bruno le maire a
aussi à préciser que ce déficit est la
prolongation de l'effort réalisé pour
non seulement protéger l'économiste mais
aussi l'accroissement de la relance et
qui permettra d'atteindre les 5 % de
croissance 5% qui je le rappelle est
l'objectif du gouvernement
autrement dit jean marc daniel pour le
gouvernement pas de croissance sans
déficit
oui je pense que c'est là que l'erreur
du gouvernement c'est d'associer
systématiquement le déficit à la
croissance économique et l'idée qu'il ne
peut y avoir de croissance que s'il ya
du déficit et de la relance budgétaire
encore une fois je maintiens le fait que
si on libère l'économie si on laisse
faire sonner l'économie comme elle
fonctionnait en 2018 2019
eh bien on aura un retour aux niveaux de
croissance qui sera un niveau de
croissance
d'abord avec un effet de rattrapage puis
ensuite le niveau de croissance qui est
relativement faible mais en fait j'ai
quand même pas négatif qui est le niveau
de croissance qu'on connaissait dans les
années
1018 2019 concrètement on voit bien que
en fait pour le gouvernement il ya trois
éléments qui jouent premiers éléments
encore une fois cette erreur de
s'engager dans la relance est une façon
d'essayer de faire en sorte que cette
relance soient payés par l'europe c'est
le corps d'idées du l'emploi européenne
a essayé d'esquiver d'une certaine façon
les conséquences son discours sur la
relance
le deuxième enjeu c'est comment on va
sortir des plans des des no tamment des
prêts garantis par l'état des pg e dans
un tissu productif alors olivier amiens
d'avoir le fait que le secteur
particulier de la restauration du
tourisme était encore très touché mais
quand on regarde l'industrie pure au
sens strict du terme
on s'aperçoit que le niveau de capacité
production utiliser le même que celui de
donc on est véritablement dans la phase
de reprise comme 2011 avait été après la
récession de 2008 2009 sur le secteur
central qu'est l'activité de
manufacturiers l'industriel et tous qui
l'entourent et donc le véritable enjeu
c'est sortir des aides et identifié
secteur par secteur le bon timing pour
sortir de ces aides
puis un dernier élément qu'il faut quand
même mettre en avant le fait qu' il y à
des élections mais il ya aussi des
partenaires européens qui sont en train
de s'agacer il faut bien voir que sur
les 27 pays de l'union européenne
il y en a treize dont la dette publique
donc là des publics c'est pas le déficit
vous l'avez bien soulignée en début
d'émission la dette publique 1 c'est le
cumul des déficits pour les
mathématiciens la des publics c'est la
primitive par rapport à la fonction de
déficit et est donc cette dette publique
elle est en dessous de 60% dans 13 pays
de l'union européenne et il est au
dessus de 100 % dans sept pays de
l'union européenne et les sept pays
étant les pays qu'on a l'habitude de
désigner sous le vocable de club med et
dans ce club med il ya la france et il
ya la france et l'italie qui sont de
plus en plus montrés du doigt par les
pays frugaux il ya eu encore récemment
des propos à ses assassins tenu par le
gouvernement autrichien et le premier
ministre néerlandais quand il aura
résolu ses problèmes de coalition je
pense qu'il repartira à l'assaut et donc
je pense que le gouvernement aussi à une
contrainte qui est son image de marque
et sa position au sein de l'union
européenne donc je pense que les vrais
enjeux sont plus sortir des pg e et
répondre aux attentes des pays frugaux
plutôt que effectivement continuer à
faire de la relance
alors on reviendra
justement sur les enjeux du côté
européen ce sera juste après la pub
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine le
déficit public avec jean marc daniel
économiste et professeur à escp europe
olivier on va regarder un peu ce qu'il
se passe en allemagne du côté du déficit
donc 9,4 pour cent du pib pour la france
contre 4 % outre-rhin
même chose du côté de la dette où elle
avoisine les 70% du pib en allemagne
contre près de 117 % du pib pour la
france
un tel écart est ce que c'est dû
uniquement à l'âge une gestion
différente de la crise ou alors est-ce
que ce serait cela résulte plutôt deux
stratégies différentes mises en place
ces dernières années non c'est sais pas
c'est pas nouveau que l'allemagne ait
moins de déficit et une dette moins
importante que la france c'est 2 ces
deux politiques totalement différente et
ça depuis très avant le co lead ça n'a
pas ça n'a pas été modifiée par le colis
alors qu'on ait eu là une gestion
catastrophique de la de la crise
sanitaire ça c'est une chose et c'est
vrai que en allemagne ça a été beaucoup
mieux gérer mes mais c'est quelque chose
que qu'on connaissait avant enfin je
veux dire on n'a pas de on n'a jamais eu
eux ont plutôt eu des déficits quasi
quasi nulle sur les sur les dernières
années pendant que nous on se on avait
joyeusement 3 ou 4% de déficit tous les
ans donc il ça ça remonte à loin face à
c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau alors
que ce soit amplifiée avec la mauvaise
gestion qui a été fait ces dernières
années
donc oui bien sûr que oui mais mais ça
n'est pas quelque chose c'est un vrai
modèle en france
de toute façon on fonctionne là dessus
on a les impôts les la part d'impôts la
plus élevée de 2 des pays européens
quasiment et vous avez toujours un
déficit important du budget de la france
donc c'est pas nouveau
en effet jean marc le disais on fait
partie des pays du club med
même si on a l'impression qu'on forme un
couple avec l'allemagne et un couple qui
est plutôt disparates quand même donc
voilà est de moins en moins un couple
alors jean granel donc olivier le dire
le déficit c'est un vrai modèle en
france est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça est-ce que c'est viable sur le
long terme est ce que on peut encore
continuer comme ça longtemps donc je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec le
diagnostic que vient de faire olivier
c'est à dire que nous vivons en france
et des avants et bien avant la crise de
l'aco vide sur l'idée qu'on peut
substituer durablement de la dépense
publique au travail et donc on peut
maintenir les 35 heures la retraite à 62
ans avoir un état providence extrêmement
généreux beaucoup plus généreux que
celui qui peut y avoir en allemagne avec
un hdd par leur tête encore une fois qui
est beaucoup plus généreux que celui qui
en allemagne et que ça n'aura pas de
conséquence ni sur notre économie ni sur
nos rapports avec nos voisins
je rappelle que notre président de la
république lorsqu'on lui avait donné le
prix charlemagne à aix-la-chapelle en
mai 2018 avait il dit de façon assez
désinvolte vis-à-vis
ses hôtes il faut savoir se débarrasser
du fétichisme des excédents budgétaires
et commerciaux et donc nous on en est
bien débarrassé sauf que des pays qui
sont peut-être des fétichistes des
excédents budgétaires et commerciaux
commencent à s'agacer et donc je pense
que sur le plan politique on prend un
véritable danger their sur le plan
économique on prend du retard on recule
on a une croissance qui croissance
potentielle qui n'est plus au
rendez-vous et sur le plan politique on
devient effectivement le mouton noir de
la classe européenne
alors comme la vie olivier là aussi au
début de l'émission il va y avoir des
élections présidentielles on est plutôt
dans une stratégie de dirigeants là
louis 15 après moi le déluge
mais le déluge il va finir par arriver
si on continue à avoir ce type de
désinvolture et d'insouciance vis-à-vis
de la situation de nos finances
publiques
comment inverser la situation et est ce
qu'il ya un risque que cela se répercute
sur nos impôts
malgré la pression fiscale actuelle
serait plus ça se répercutera d'une
façon ou d'une autre c'est à dire qu'on
sait très bien que la dette c'est c111
report d'impôt en fait il voulait
c'est-à-dire que vous finirez par le
payer cette histoire est donc plus vous
vous endettez plus vous des cas alors
vous décalez leleu l'impôt que vous
auriez dû payer tout de suite le
problème c'est parce qu'on ne veut pas
faire ce qu'il faut c'est à dire on ne
veut pas baisser les dépenses publiques
alors ça veut pas dire couper des
crédits à des activités essentielles
mais ça veut dire d'abord les
réorganiser ça veut dire ne pas dépenser
des centaines de milliards pour des
trucs qui servent à rien je reparle un
petit des éoliennes c'est ma petite
marotte mais c'est une absurdité on le
sait on sait que ça marche pas on sait
que ça fonctionne pas on sait que ça
peut lui mais on s'en fout on met quand
même 200 milliards dessus donc
évidemment que cet argent serait
peut-être mieux employé ailleurs et vous
continuez à creuser le déficit parce que
vous ne vous
les absolument pas réduire en fait le
train de vie de l'état en quoi que ce
soit et donc vous aurez un déficit qui
va continuer à gonfler croissance ou pas
croissance parce que toute façon même si
on a une reprise on va retomber après
sur la moyenne de croissance sur la
croissance potentielle et la croissance
potentielle
en france elle est de 1 aller 1 2
maximum
donc si vous voulez ça ne ça ne peut pas
avec 1,2 pour cent de croissance vous ne
pouvez pas diminuer le chômage
rembourser les emprunts accéda donc il
n'y a pas assez d'argent donc lié à ce
moment là ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que probablement ça passera en effet
parlé par les impôts mais cette espèce
de cette espèce de mentalité française
ou de deux modèles français qui cherche
à remplacer l'activité par de la dette
c'est un truc moi qui m'échappe
totalement je comprends pas où ils ont
fait leurs études d'économie et où ils
ont vu comment que ça pouvait marcher
comme ça vous ne pouvez pas remplacé du
chiffre d'affaires par de la dette
c'est une absurdité et pourtant c'est ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
fait avec les pg e par exemple avec en
plus aucun discernement c'est à dire que
vous donnez d'aider des prêts garantis
par l'état à des boîtes qui de toute
façon sont foutus sont mortes
elle était bien avant le coc vide donc
on subventionne si vous voulez des
entreprises zombies et il n'y a rien de
pire parce que ça fait évidemment moins
d'argent pour celles qui auraient pu en
bénéficier et qu'ils avaient un modèle
économique qui était viable
là on s'amuse à entretenir des choses
qui ne sont pas viables et
malheureusement il faudra qu'un jour on
accepte de débrancher la prise pour que
ces entreprises là passe la main jean
marc daniel un déficit public qui gonfle
c'est aussi une dette publique qui
augmente vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure
nous évoluant au sein de l'union
européenne avec un pacte de stabilité
que les pays se sont engagés à respecter
à quelles conséquences à long terme pour
lui
mais je pense que effectivement sur le
plan de l'union européenne
on voit apparaître un vrai clivage une
vraie tension maintenant entre le nord
et le sud entre les frigos et les pays
donc de ce qu'on appelle plus ou moins
le club med et je pense que
on l'a vu au moins de la négociation sur
le célèbre désormais célèbre plan de
relance européen les pays du nord ont
combien mais quand même bien d'avoir le
fait qu' il était disposé à être
solidaire des pays du sud dans une
situation délicate pour eux mais que sa
supposée que les pays du sud fasse un
effort est d'ailleurs notre gouvernement
en a plus ou moins conscience quand il
remet sur la table le problème des
retraites c'est que c'est un des sujets
sur lequel reviennent le plus
régulièrement nos partenaires européens
en disant que la france est le pays où
on parle plutôt à la retraite en europe
c'était le cas avec la slovaquie jusque
avec des dernières mais la slovaquie
vient de reporter son âge de départ à la
retraite
donc je pense que si nous ne remettons
pas de l'ordre dans nos finances
publiques et dans nos pratiques de
gestion à la fois des deniers de l'état
mais aussi de notre état providence et
bien on va vers alors peut-être pas un
clash pas forcément une affrontement
brutal mais une paralysie des instances
européennes on l'a vu là aussi avec la
négociation de la nouvelle négociation
de la politique agricole commune
alors que les pays avaient été
relativement solidaire dans leurs
affrontements avec le royaume-uni pour
le break si tu l'as dans la politique
agricole commune de nouveau le clivage
s'est fait et de nouveau on a montré du
doigt la france et l'italie
donc je crois qu'il faut remettre de
l'ordre dans nos finances publiques avec
un engagement qui avait été pris par le
gouvernement de dominique de villepin à
la suite du rapport pébereau en 2005 qui
disait nous allons bloquer en euros
courants c'était en montant affiché le
budget de l'état au niveau où il était
en 2005 j'espère que nous soyons à l'
équilibre des finances publiques
je pense qu'on dirait la même chose on
dira écoutez on va bloquer le budget de
l'état à son niveau actuel jusqu'à ce
que nous soyons arrivés rééquilibrer son
budget et bien ce serait un engagement
simples claires se seraient pas tous les
débats qui a vu autour on avait confié à
monsieur à retenir des besoins une
mission sur comment expliquer tout ça
revenir à des règles simples claires et
que nos autres partenaires pourraient
accepter pourrait comprendre comme étant
effectivement eu un effort de notre part
merci à beaucoup jean marc daniel
d'avoir accepté notre invitation à dans
cette émission je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et professeur à lui à cp
europe et que votre dernier
il était une fois l'argent magique est
disponible aux éditions du cherche midi
qu'olivier nous on continue avec les
questions cash question de jérôme
olivier ne serait-il pas possible de
prélever une partie des dividendes
versés aux actionnaires par le cac40
pour rembourser les aides que l'état
leur a versé bien écouter le mécanisme
existe déjà ça s'appelle l'impôt donc
l'état récupère une partie de ce
dividende par les impôts et je vous
rappelle aussi que l'état est
actionnaire d'un certain nombre de
sociétés du cac 40 et que donc il est
ravi que ces sociétés distribuent du
dividende parce que le dividende tombe
dans les poches de l'état
donc non le le ce mécanisme où on donne
des subventions on accorde des prêts
garantis par l'état a à d sociétés qui
derrière vert du dividende il faut tout
simplement interdire à une société qui
touchent des aides de verser du
dividende
les autres celles qui ne touchent pas
dead et qui fonctionne bien et qui donc
font un résultat positif peuvent verser
du dividende parce que il n'y a aucune
raison qu'elle ne puisse pas le faire
mais celles qui touchent des aides de
l'état
il n'y a aucune raison que les
actionnaires ce clown touchent des
dividendes mais ça embêterait aussi
beaucoup l'état qui est un des gros
actionnaires de sociétés du cac 40
merci beaucoup olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez vous la semaine
prochaine en attendant pour voir ou
revoir nos précédents numéros rendez
vous sur notre site internet à l'adresse
rt france point tv et puis n'oubliez pas
de poser vos questions à olivier sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag rt cash
olivier le mot de la fin si seulement si
seulement ces pays frugaux pouvait
s'énerver au point de sortir de l'europe
et de faire éclater
l'euro et l'europe ça serait une bonne
nouvelle de ce qu vide